first we've agreed that all scientific
publications must be freely accessible
by 2020 the results of publicly funded
research is currently not accessible to
people outside universities and as a
result teachers doctors entrepreneurs do
not have access to the latest scientific
insights that can be relevant to their
work and universities have to take out
expensive country subscriptions with
publishers to gain access to
publications these council conclusions
will change that or in the words of
leery Christmas is over by 2020 open
access will be a reality scientific
publications will be freely accessible
to everyone to make your more attractive
for foreign startups the council has
invited the commission and interest of
member states to look into a startup
visa this will help the entrepreneurs
behind startups from outside the
European Union when they come to Europe
they will not have to apply for a
separate visa in each member state
individually an evaluation of the
seventh framework programme shows that
every euro invested in research has
generated an estimated 11 euros as a
turn-off for example through innovations
through new technologies through new
products and this is why the council
sends a strong political message
sufficient investments in knowledge and
research are needed the fp7 that had a
budget of around 55 billion years funded
more than 25,000 projects and delivered
in different accounts and I think that
in day that we have to look back we have
to look back and see what we've done
well and the fp7 delivered in growth and
jobs which I think it's really very
important for
research in science the economic growth
that is expected and estimated by the
evaluation team is that it will be
around 20 billion years per year over 25
years so around 500 billion of economic
direct and indirect effects and create
hundreds and thousands of jobs fp7 had
projects that actually screened for
instance methods for diabetes and
alzheimer disease others on robotics and
develop intelligence against terrorism
and invested in renewable energy as a
matter of examples